without failure you'd have no success
your family could eventually between the
Freitas under sighs yeah the only
failure is not to try
what's that believe nation it seven my
one word is believed and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and make a
difference using it now instead of the
one rule series because I watched lava
top tens we make a lot of top ten
content for you and some of the rules
get repeated over and over and over and
over again and so the goal of this
series is to smush together all of those
similar rules into one video so today
we're gonna learn about how there is no
success without failure enjoy people are
just afraid man so many people are
afraid of rejection of failure but
without failure you'd have no success
what was the one that stung the most as
far as failures we're stuck the most
biggest failure I had a TV show called
the big house got picked up by ABC they
told me that we were gonna do 12
episodes flew me down to New York this
is the biggest news ever I'm about to be
rich holy Sh I'm 22 I got a TV show I'm
writing executive producing starring in
the show you know what no I'm not just
gonna go down there by myself we got to
bring the cash they said no Kevin we
only flying you I said well I'm a pay
for the cast to come I took my own money
flew them all down in New York get to
New York put on my suit people taking
pictures of me walking out this is the
best thing ever
holy Sh I'm famous this is what it is I
get to the up front up front so where
they turn out your TV shows the slew of
shows they're announcing their time
slots I'm next they're bout that now
it's the big house somebody puts their
hand on my chest and says Kevin wait
they talking to earpiece they said nope
I'm standing with him right now I'm like
what's going on what they want me to do
you know they want me go on the other
side or something he goes okay I'll tell
him they cancelled they're not gonna
pick you up you got to step back and I
was like that don't sound right
literally that fast they sent me home
they're like you gotta just go home TV
show got picked up six months later for
six episodes the third episodes aired
they
hands will show again I got the show
can't do twice in a six-month period
which has never been done before I
booked about three more pilots got
cancelled there was a show called John
Stamos his show he was a publicist and
they wanted me as a series regular the
show was going great ratings were good
put me on the show show got canceled
it was everything got touched on TV
tundish I'm now just sitting out here
doing nothing
I handle money borrow money left him
right I decided to say forget I said I'm
just gonna do stand-up comedy and focus
on my craft and I slaved the role for
about five years doing the same circuit
over and over again I think if you don't
fail you're not doing it right
to be honest I think you should be
failing often but it's important it
teaches you your limits and shows you
like the limits you need to pass nobody
ever made mistakes
I could be really boring it's true yeah
if you only try to succeed then you're
limiting yourself to not to fail which
your failure can eventually believe the
greatest underside yeah never be afraid
of not getting it right or failing or
not getting the part or not getting the
job like it's just one more notch in
your belt but you're still gonna wear
that the long piece of leather with tons
of room for more notches nobody sees
they're like 17 plus years of work that
I've done before today where you finally
stumbled upon a video of mine we're try
so hard in our lives to fit in we try to
fit into certain groups certain frats
certain sororities you know amongst
certain friends yet the people we
idolize our most are the ones that stand
out but when you're prepared there is no
fear there is no fear of failure okay
because even if you've walked out of
something and you feel like you've
failed at it your preparation is so
strong that you're gonna take that
failure and turn it into the outcome you
desire and most people stop at failure
okay we've all failed at things I'm
gonna continue to fail at stuff
it's the most powerful tool you can use
but it all depends on how you use it you
know we talked about it in relentless
okay a scalpel okay in the hands of an
individual it can do unbelievable damage
in the hands of a professional of a
doctor it saves lives
so it's the same thing with failure it's
how you use it it's that drive inside of
you
okay it's what we talk about the dark
side the dark side is filled with
failure but it's the fuel that burns you
like something that's never burned
inside you before you're probably gonna
fail yeah the stuff you do is probably
gonna suck you're probably gonna get in
trouble yeah probably not gonna work are
you okay with that as if you're not okay
with that well then that's why you're
having trouble getting your ideas out
there that's why you're having trouble
integrating other people into the team
that's why you're having trouble doing X
Y & Z because you aren't okay with it
not working so you're waiting for the
thing that's sure to work but the thing
that's sure to work isn't gonna happen
yeah and if it is someone's gonna do it
instead of you so all that's left are
the things that are probably not gonna
work yeah the thing is when you were
four you told the joke that was funny
and when you were eight you did a
drawing that was interesting yeah when
you were 14 you had a conversation with
someone that was truly human you're
capable of it
that's not the question everyone who's
watching this has written one
intelligent sentence I've just written
more than one but it's a matter of
quantity not ability yeah so where does
the quantity come from the quantity
comes from being willing to be wrong
being willing to be made fun of being
willing to be embarrassed being willing
to fail it never gets easier it never
gets fun
ever okay fine and gravity also sucks
if we didn't have gravity we could fly
yeah so there's gravity but we don't
whine about gravity we just acknowledge
that there's gravity and we walk anyway
yeah well I think the same thing is true
about the art that we make the
difference that we make that a customer
comes in every day and the fifth day
they come in that looks like they've
been crying it is not your job to say to
them is everything okay and give
Mahad but if you did that what would
happen right it might not work
they might get really angry with you in
your business but it also might change
their life you could sign up for that or
not and that's what freedom looks like
and that's why freedom is so scary
because freedom doesn't come with a
dummies book and freedom doesn't come
with a permit and freedom doesn't come
with an excuse you have to own it and it
probably isn't gonna work you know I've
written 7,000 blog posts and half of
them were below average I just didn't
know which ones were below average until
after I wrote it if you want to succeed
then you need to adjust how you see
failure failure is going to happen if
you look at the most successful people
in the world who studied them where in
the book they're all over the channel
they feel the most the most successful
person and you look up to that use like
wow that person is so successful I can't
believe it they have failed way more
than you even try not everything works
out most of the series that I put out on
this channel don't work out we test
constantly and most of them never go
anywhere they just don't get enough
traction there's an experiment we failed
we move on to the next one we have
failed more than most people even try
and that's why we succeed and that's a
consistent habit around people who are
winning they win because they tried so
many other things and a certain
percentage make their way through and
most people are so afraid to fail but
they don't even try and that's the
biggest failure of all they're so afraid
of it not working out there but not
being the big hit but they just sit on
their idea and then they watch somebody
else make tons of money you have a huge
impact from it get it out there may not
be the biggest version of what you're
trying to do but start start small build
momentum see if you still even like this
thing or not see if you can get some
people interested in our line and expect
to fail failure is not the enemy failure
is normal
failure is welcomed right you're gonna
learn from it you're gonna build on it
you're gonna make it better if you are
not feeling if you're winning every time
think about it like if you're winning
every time everything you touch wins
that means you're playing a tiny game it
means you're racing against
three-year-olds great congratulations
you want every single race because
you're running against three-year-olds
if you want to be the best you want to
have an impact you want to make your
business a success you want to make
money you want
reach people you're gonna have to race
against people who are a little more
skilled and talented you're gonna have
to risk losing you're not gonna win
every race but the good news is you
don't have to you don't have to win
every race to succeed you just have to
win one you can run a hundred races you
just need to win one and then they call
you an overnight success so often you
don't move forward because you're
keeping such score from what didn't work
in the past you are holding yourself
hostage to 1997 to 2005 you're holding
yourself hostage in love to that past
relationship that didn't work or you're
holding yourself in hostage in business
to the money that you may have thought
you wasted or the deal that went bad and
so one of the ways that I give myself
permission for two levels permission to
have lived a life that has some
beautiful experiences and some really
tangy lessons I mean they're spicy they
hurt they're painful when I give myself
permission to have had that I also give
myself permission to keep leaping give
myself permission to keep dreaming give
myself permission to keep learning how
to get it right learning how to love the
unlovable forgive what seems to be the
unforgivable to leap again even while I
still have a bandage on my chin from the
last time I fell I still get to leave
someone invite you if you fall fall
catch your breath
put a bandage on it whether you fail
financially you fail physically with
health and wellness you feel spiritually
you felt emotionally you felt in a
relationship okay a part of flying is
understanding what the distinction
between flying and falling and the only
way you understand the distinction is
that you experience full life when you
experience full life it's like this life
isn't just flatline is not just like
this you make your Heights feel better
because you understand this was a
failure and what I mean by a failures
this taught me a lesson
stung this every single failure has a
lesson in it to me a failure is a lesson
wrapped in some sticky icky paper that
stung that hurt and so give yourself
permission give yourself permission to
play big to be nervous to fall down to
sit down for a minute just don't take up
real estate in the sitting down don't
take up real estate in the analyzing
don't take don't take up real estate in
the preparation you've been getting
prepared for a long time for something
trust that you'll either fly if you leap
right now or you're fall if you leak
right now and if you fly you'll
understand what soaring feels like and
if you fall you'll understand what
getting up feels like either way you're
okay that's how I play big with my knees
knocking and that's how I play big even
when there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time I did something like this and it
didn't quite work out and I still play
big because I gave myself I give myself
I constantly give myself permission to
totally win and soar are totally falling
it up and that way there's nothing to
truly be afraid of
remember this is a dialogue not a
monologue which means we're in a dynamic
conversation versus me just entertaining
you perfectionism doesn't advance
anything ironically as a creative and as
a designer there's no wrong way to go
about the future of your career the only
the only failure is not to try you know
and I think that designers we all have
like a creators or artists we have a
natural convention to sort of be maybe
tormented or a little bit of like an
inner struggle is is the work living up
to its fullest potential or is it you
know is it as great as the work that you
analyze from your design idols but at
the end of the day it's your body of
work and it's the amount of work and the
refinement of that work that will define
who you are as a creative Isaiah Berlin
famously said to understand is to
perceive patterns that's in essence what
creativity is Steve Jobs says creativity
is just connecting things but in order
to see patterns and rather in order to
recombine existing patterns into new
forms and new shapes you need to be
willing to blur the boundaries between
your thoughts right to be an
associational thinker right it's a free
style to ride a butterfly affecting
thought but again most of the time we
play it safe right we map out what we're
gonna say we pre plan what we're gonna
do we make a list we have a set of steps
we are prepared we've pre-scripted our
speech right we are responsible we're
not going into a situation blind but
again once in a while my friends we need
to be willing to make a mistake we need
to be willing to fail it is only when we
risk making a mistake that we might find
ourselves improvising inventing
innovating our way back to where we want
to get to do you understand what I'm
saying
think of this rant as a metaphor for the
creative process right I have
somewhat an idea of what I want to say
right it's related to creativity and
it's related to cognitive dissonance and
being willing to make a mistake that's
all I know then they start jamming about
this and what happens is I might lose
myself in some chain of thought right I
just kind of lose myself in the moment
the metaphor might like confound me and
before I know it I don't even remember
what I was saying but somehow that's
when the creativity kicks in because
somehow I've got to bring it back I've
got a rope it in I've got to remember
where I'm going I've got a some
incoherence right in the Bardot's
between one statement and the other and
in doing so and in risking screwing up
the video and the tape it is in that
risk that the courage that the
innovation that the creativity that the
original thought might emerge and
usually does and before I know it I've
landed and I feel like wow man I just
took a trip man you know I just sailed
into the great unknown and I brought it
back and here we are
that is what creativity is all about
that is the risk that is there be the
willingness to fail and make a mistake
that is crucial to the creative process
have you ever done a trip that didn't
work almost every single one in front of
people failed something that all the
good news about doing magic is and I
think like rappers too it's like you
never know where the end is because it's
up to him so it's you you can keep
improvising and going so there's never a
failure unless you quit so if you keep
going there's not a failure just keep
changing and moving I feel like my
example and the thing that I try and
inspires to being yourself is again with
the thing with Instagram and social
media it does become very contrived and
controlled and I think the most
important thing is can't oppose that
thing of be falling over flat on my face
because we all do it it's you know it's
okay to make mistakes it's okay to fail
my whole thing my biggest fear was
failure and it's ridiculous because
again the imperfections of human or what
makes us so great we need to celebrate
those things what were you worried about
failing right now they've been good
enough out you know trying to Pete
major people-pleaser really fun oh yeah
now I've got a really special jay Shetty
bonus clip on how to redefine failure
that I think you're really gonna enjoy
but before that commitment of the day I
want to know what are you committing to
changing in your life or your business
after watching this video leave it down
in the comments below when you write it
down that commitment is much more likely
to happen so let's see what you got
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
and enjoy the bonus clip
in the middle of 2009 he was the
software engineer that no one wanted to
hire he had 12 years of experience at
Yahoo but he was rejected by Facebook
and then rejected by Twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great CV but he decided to team up with
one of his alumni members at Yahoo and
started to create an app and focus on
the startup space in five years time he
sold that out for 19 billion dollars to
Facebook believe it or not that was
Brian Acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from Facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people I
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by Twitter he
responded by saying worked-out ills by a
long commute it's so interesting to see
that someone rejected from two of the
top Internet companies actually
responded with humor and actually
responded with positivity this lady was
diagnosed with clinical depression her
marriage had failed and she was jobless
with a dependent child she was on a
4-hour delayed train journey from
Manchester to London when she came up
with this idea and she started to write
this book about this wizard and as she
started writing she then finished her
manuscript to get her 12 publishers and
was rejected by all 12 believe it or not
that's JK Rowling this man watched his
first company crumble he was a Harvard
University dropout and his first
company's demo didn't even work he went
on to build Microsoft his name's Bill
Gates
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we need to be
ready and build ourselves up for the
next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle
except well he thought was our goal what
we thought we were chasing but actually
I've noticed that when you don't get
that later down the line you look back
and you reflect and realize that what
you've gained is so much greater
failures are only failures when we don't
learn from them because when we learn
from them they become lessons and we
actually extract aller all of these
teachings and actually get more insight
into how we can improve the way we work
and how we can actually drive with a
different energy the challenge we have
is that we only talk about people's
failures when they succeed and that's
why they become this taboo or we feel
like their failures never happened we
need to share these stories earlier we
need to bring out these stories and
experiences on the journey so that
people who are on the journey can
actually follow in those footsteps
and that's why Steve Jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that that
people your passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your that's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
most of success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details